We've got an interesting voice mail today.
The phone number to call is two one nine two
David P.
This voicemail has what I guess is now the
requisite podcast playing in the background
pause of the show to call in.
Remember, you can just hit pause and then
call me and then resume.
But in any case, you'll hear my voice in the
back.
And let's take a listen to this voicemail.
Hey, David, I was just wondering, what are
your thoughts on if President Trump was to
lose the election and he doesn't want to leave
office?
Right, we do.
Listen, don't worry about that.
OK, there's a couple different things there.
Number one, don't put the cart before the
horse.
Let's defeat Trump first before we worry about
whether he'll leave office.
That's the most important thing, because if
we focus too much on what will happen if Trump
refuses to leave office, Trump might get himself
reelected.
And we don't want that.
That's number one.
So just go vote number two.
If Donald Trump loses in November, on January
21st, 2021, he will no longer be the president
of the United States.
He just will not be the president.
OK.
That's the way that it is written in the law.
And I am not particularly worried about Donald
Trump successfully not turning over power
to Joe Biden.
If he loses in November, I do believe Trump
will claim that it was rigged.
I do believe that it is likely that many Trump
ists could be moved to get on the streets,
possibly with guns, if Donald Trump convinces
them that it was rigged and that really Donald
Trump won.
I believe all of that that could well happen.
But Trump will leave because he will not be
the president anymore on January 21st.
Now, I know that there are some hypotheses
floating around.
Here's what Trump could do to prevent this
from going to Joe Biden in January, if indeed
he were to lose.
Most of those scenarios actually lead to the
speaker of the House becoming president.
It's important to understand it doesn't mean
there is not some hypothetical scenario that
you could dream up of some way Trump could
remain in the White House.
I don't worry about voting right now.
OK.
That's the important thing.
We've got three and a half months until November.
Let's win first, then we'll have two more
two and a half more months to make sure Donald
Trump vacates the White House.
And we'll deal with that after November 3rd
if that comes up.
But let's just leave it there.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We are going to talk about the U.S. budget
deficit.
Where are the deficit hawks?
They're very, very quiet as the U.S. budget
deficit has hit another all time high.
Disney World is also offering MASC free relaxation
zones.
I will discuss how much would I have to be
paid to go to Disney World right now?
Not how much would I pay?
Would I go with it?
How much would I have to be paid to go?
And we are also going to talk about China
announcing some sanctions against Marco Rubio
and Ted Cruz, two Republican senators, retaliatory
sanctions against them.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show.
Don't miss it.
Become a member.
Join Pacman icon.